I listen to my gut it's not an emotion
it's an index of risk if you're making
decisions only based op logic you're
living in the past trust your gut
it's so important to trust your gut rise
and shine it's in spresso time good
morning believe nation it's evan my one
word is believe and i believe in you i
believe you have an amazing gift inside
to you that i want to see exploded onto
the world so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message trust your gut over
to you kevin o'leary recently i was with
a bunch of other investors of i respect
and they brought me a deal and i wanted
to be part of it
but it didn't feel right and I wrote
millions of dollars on that one and it
just didn't feel right and I lost it all
within two years so investors dress hair
got dinner absolutely in trust you or
what about you said earlier don't be
emotional and sometimes the gonna know
this this is a barometer of risk it's
something an internalized for an
investor that says I don't feel
comfortable it's not about emotions just
don't write that check that was recently
the first time I didn't listen to that
and I lost everything so now my radar is
up I listen to my gut
it's not an emotion it's an index of
risk and you get it as you age you
become a better investor every year if
only I could live to 200 I'd be really
good making smart decisions as a result
of getting experience getting experience
as a result of making a lot of stupid
decisions and so I loved when he was
talking about in this video that the
experience that you get gut is a
barometer of experience it's not just an
emotional thing it's something that
comes from the ongoing experience that
you get from doing the thing that you're
trying to do I love using my gut as a
factor in me making the decisions
the big ones because logic yes has its
place but if you're making decisions
just based on what's logical then you're
living in a world that currently exists
and part of what we do as entrepreneurs
is we're trying to create something new
right the world will evolve and change
without you the logic that exists right
now will not be in place in 25 years in
ten years and five years maybe even next
year and so if you're making decisions
only based on logic you're living in the
past and that can serve you but it's
definitely not the complete picture with
every especially major decision that
you're make you want to make sure that
you feel it that even if it doesn't work
out even if you fail it's worth knowing
I had this experience when I was 18
years old that fundamentally rocked my
life I was in Paris I wanted to ask this
girl out end of the day I was too afraid
and I took a picture and I posted on my
wall of the scenery and I looked at that
every day as a reminder to myself that
the next time I wanted to do something I
would have the courage to push through
the fear push through the potential
failure and do it and that inspired me
to the next year when I had my chance to
have my own software company or go get
these super high-paying jobs which one
would I regret potentially not doing
what does my gut tell me to do and my
gut told me I need to at least try this
thing I'm evil it'll work I mean really
amazing and luckily it worked out but
maybe it'll flame up maybe it won't work
maybe would this be a terrible decision
maybe I've just wasted a year of my life
trying this thing and I was okay with
that
because at least I knew or I think a lot
of people we have a gut feeling on
something you have a gut feeling what
you want to do you have a gut response
to how you want to deal with situation
but you don't listen to it and you do
the only logical thing to do and you
live your entire life in the safe lane
you're never going to accomplish
anything great because again you're just
living according to the rules of the
past and so the next time you get that
feeling do the thing that you got tells
you to do you could do what I did where
I had that failure moment right that not
listening to my gut not listening to my
intuition taking a picture and putting
on my wall as that
you Overmind there you could do
something similar think of an
opportunity missed
think of a chance of an idea that you
had and put that visual on your wall
somewhere so you look at the daily as a
constant reminder because these ideas
that you have somebody else is gonna
make millions of dollars off of them if
you don't and you have no right in five
years to say that was my idea he made
millions
she made millions and I'm still stuck
here where I was in the same place five
years ago you have no right to complain
about it because it's your fault because
you didn't take the action on it because
you didn't listen to your gut so whether
you have a visual reminder whether you
write something down on a piece of paper
whether this video just inspires that
for you the next time you have that
feeling in your gut that this feels
right or that this feels wrong or that
you just need to know then learn to
listen to it I use the heart gut heart
you can talk yourself into her out of
anything your heart notes you got to
listen to it now I have a special bonus
clip for you but before getting to it I
want to know what was the last decision
that you made with your gut instead of
one listen to logic and did it work out
or not because a lot of them may not
work out but you learn from it let me
know and leave it down in the comments
below thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
trust your gut it's so important to
trust your gut
you know I saw a man speak one time and
he said I'll prove to you in four words
there's no such thing as a bad idea and
he said Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles ha
ha so I'm here today to prove to you in
two words there's no such thing as a bad
idea and that's footless pantyhose so no
matter what your ideas are you're doing
something better than your competitors
that's why you're in business you've
thought of an idea that's why you're
here and and then be prepared for the
opportunity as a young entrepreneur I
learned seven valuable lesson but I
think the most valuable lesson I learned
was trusting your own gut instinct it's
not about the spreadsheets
it's not about the numbers it is about
what you feel in your heart just
remember there's so many variables in
the real life
spreadsheets can never capture them the
brain only works on the logic of zeros
and one and it doesn't know how to deal
with a lot of gray areas your gut your
heart is a chemical computer it computes
things on a fuzzy fuzzy magic fuzzy
logic that means a lot of the times
you'll start to feel that something
doesn't feel right even though the
numbers do add up it's you know it's
just a gut feeling I think I think I
always trust my gut that's all I have I
even when I'm working and you're
thinking about the shape of a scene and
how it should be played and and your
head can often get in the way and you
gotta trust you've got and I it's just
if I'm inspired if my curiosity is
piqued and I want to chase this
possibility down that I see in front of
me on my desk you know it's um and some
of you may have heard me say this before
but it and I always I'm embarrassed to
say I always speak in metaphors I don't
know how to speak in any other way and
and for me acting is it's kind of like
playing the piano and and and if the
piano is the human condition and we all
have every single note on that 88 key
board
in us and for me every role I want to be
able to play every note and some and
sometimes if a character or a story
seems to seem to stretch me in some way
seems to to offer up an experience that
is new that is a different chord or a
different tune that I that is that is
that is real and true and human and and
accessible and no matter how joyous or
or loving or warm or how dark or painful
if it seems like an interesting shape to
inhabit I'm running I know if I'm
running towards it already raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people with passion
can not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's suppose to mean I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details